vélos taxis rickshaw cyclo pousse ici on
les appelle paix niqab
il slalome avec souplesse dans la
circulation taux d'émission de co2 zéro
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles à
new york ils ont le vent en poupe
mais ce ne serait pas un peu dangereux
ce n'est pas dangereux parce que je suis
un professionnel vous savez ivan
petrenko et ukrainiens je loue ce vélo
150 dollars par semaine à mon boss et je
dois payer en plus pour chaque course le
système n'est pas très différent de
celui des taxis jaunes avec une exigence
quand même en plus la forme physique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avantage du pdi cab on peut découvrir
des endroits interdits à la voiture
alors là c'est la rentrée du poids 7e
on est dans l'intersection de 500
personnes et
certains revenus mehdi et marocains il
parle bilangue avec une préférence pour
le français quand vous voyez les chevaux
c'est une chose inité
très populaire ici dans le froid depuis
des dizaines d'années bien avant l'épée
d'icab et les taxis jaunes les fiacres
où les calèches étaient un moyen de
locomotion naturel à new york à l'entrée
de central park un abreuvoir rappelle
l'époque où la ville comptait plus de
150 mille chevaux
conor mc young et irlandaises il ya pas
mal d'autres cochet qui sont d'origine
irlandaise
je me suis retrouvé dans ce business car
je connaisse à l'époque quelqu'un qui
était déjà et j'y suis toujours
quel est l'intérêt de circuler à new
york en calèche et bien c'est un
excellent remède contre le stress
ce qu'on fait surtout à new york c est
courir dans tous les sens on a
l'impression qu'ici tout bouge plus vite
qu'ailleurs
et vous aussi vous prenez le rythme donc
les calèches sont un moyen de vous
relaxer et en quelque sorte de remonter
le temps et puis c'est tellement
romantique
oasis de verdure au milieu d'une forêt
de gratte-ciels central park est le plus
grand parc urbain des états unis il
regorge d'endroits intéressant ce parc
devant nous c'est là où john lennon
passé la plupart de son temps avant
qu'il a été assassiné
[Musique]
tout au long de l'été central park est
le théâtre de nombreux concerts gratuits
[Musique]
fathallah
[Applaudissements]
alors si vous regardez au delà du parc
de ce côté c'est deux tours sans dans le
film sos fantômes
ce sont les tours san remo l'actrice
demi moore villa dans l'appartement au
dernier étage dustin hoffman et diane
keaton habite aussi dans tout l'espace
de nos moyens et de montant les moutons
broutent est ici de 1890 puisqu'à la
crise économique des etats-unis en 1930
aujourd'hui les amateurs de bronzage ont
remplacé les moutons
mais les canards les tortues et les
chevaux sont toujours là central park
devait être une oasis en dehors de la
vie réelle
ce sont les gens riches de l'époque qui
ont dit nous voulons pouvoir emmener nos
calèche dans le parc
le concepteur du parc alors fait une
concession en disant d'accord à
condition que ce soit vos plus belles
calèche et vos plus beaux chevaux qui
dit cheval dix écuries
ici comme ailleurs le cheval a besoin
d'un toit et comme à new york tout se
fait en vertical les calèches reste au
rez de chaussée et les chevaux sont
installés dans les étages
[Musique]